when they repealed alcohol prohibition
it was left up to the states what to do
with alcohol and so you have most of the
Republican presidential candidates
saying the federal government should not
interfere if States want to legalize
that's really an amazing development
Jacob solemn has been writing for Reason
magazine since I was a senior in high
school which coincidentally is about the
time that I picked up Reason magazine
for the very first time and notice there
were all these wonderful writers who
were advocating for the legalization of
drugs today Jacob Salem is a senior
editor at reason he's a nationally
syndicated columnist he's the author of
the great book saying yes in defense of
drug use and he blogs about drug policy
at forbes.com I'll just start off with
the most basic question why is it
important and good that pot be legal
well it's a few reasons its first of all
unjust to treat people like criminals
for engaging behavior that violates no
one's rights that's the most basic thing
for me so I would say the first point is
that prohibition is unjust second point
is that it's unscientific to the extent
that people think that the drugs we ban
are somehow worse than the drugs that we
don't ban that's clearly not true if you
compare marijuana to alcohol marijuana
is less dangerous by several important
measures so that distinction does not
make sense it's arbitrary which makes
the injustice of prohibition worse I
guess because it's not even based on a
distinction that makes sense
and finally it's unconstitutional I mean
people may remember that back when they
banned alcohol they needed a
constitutional amendment for that this
Congress didn't have the power to ban a
commodity just because members of
Congress didn't like it that everybody
assumed that you needed to have an
amendment but somehow when it came time
to ban marijuana they didn't need an
amendment the Constitution had not
changed
initially it was disguised as a revenue
measure it was a prohibitive tax that
was imposed on marijuana but then later
on by the time of the Controlled
Substances Act around 1970 this was
rationalized under the Commerce Clause
this was a form of regulating interstate
commerce but the way that's been
interpreted
by the Supreme Court is that even if
you're growing pot in your own closet or
your own backyard and it never leaves
your your property let alone the state
that's still somehow is interstate
commerce and there was a case not not
too long ago involving medical marijuana
in California where they said even if
you were a patient and a growing
marijuana to treat your symptoms and
that's allowed by state law and even if
you make your grow your own marijuana
even if you get it somewhere else and
you possess it you have a little bag of
it in your dresser somehow that can be
reached by the interstate commerce
clause which really makes no sense so
the powers of the federal government
have been vastly expanded by stretching
the commerce clause to cover basically
anything Congress wants to do and
marijuana prohibition is one of many
examples of that well given that picture
it's amazing how much has really changed
right because now medical marijuana is
legal in about two dozen states and I
know the elections of 2016 are about a
year away and so it's looking a bit
forward but do you have a sense of like
how that's going to how the battles are
going to shape out because pot is going
to be on the on the ballot for in about
what half a dozen states well oh hi oh
was this year and that went down in
flames yeah
largely for two reasons it was bad
timing because it was an off year
election the people who are inclined to
support marijuana legalization are more
likely to vote in the presidential
election year the more likely be
Democrats more likely to be younger
those people tend to favor legalization
more and secondly it had a major flaw in
it where it would have created a
cannabis cultivation cartel it would
have limited commercial production to
ten sites that were controlled by the
people who were the financial backers of
the initiative so a lot of people didn't
like that including a lot of people who
otherwise support legalization so that
lost by nearly a two-to-one margin it
was a huge disaster I think next year
California is the biggest one there's a
good shot it's going to pass it's kind
of surprising that California has not
legalized marijuana by now was the first
state to legalize marijuana for medical
use but an initiative to realize it for
recreational use lost by think four
points several years ago the poll
it looks pretty good is around 55%
according to one recent poll so that
that's I would say that's the most
likely state to legalize and that would
be huge
do you remember a time because you've
been covering this for quite a while now
do you remember a time when this was
like crazy talk right I mean back in
this certainly the early 90s late 80s or
the just say no era yeah I mean it makes
me very uneasy now because I'm
uncomfortable being in the majority and
when I read the New York Times says we
should legalize marijuana I think maybe
I should re-evaluate my position because
that bets makes me nervous
but you know when I first started
working at Reason public support for
legalization was probably less than it
less than a quarter of Americans
supported it support peaked in the late
70s around 28% but then during the
Reagan administration in the early 80s I
think it bottomed out at around 23% and
then it started going up again it's kind
of gradually and then a little bit more
sharply and since then it's been moving
steadily upward and until we get to
majority support for legalization and
who were the allies and the opponents of
drug legalization back then and versus
today and how has that changed it was
primarily lefties with a smattering of
libertarians not surprisingly
so basically lefties and libertarians
progressive people who might call them
sell progressives a few conservatives
for example William F Buckley and other
editors International and National
Review supported marijuana legalization
before a lot of other conservatives did
but the conservative movement in general
was very strongly anti-drug it's very
striking if you look at the Republican
presidential candidates and there are a
lot of them this year that most of them
actually support is letting the states
decide they won't they don't necessarily
say we like legalization in fact they
generally don't say that and they may
even say I don't want to legalize
marijuana but they say it should be left
up to space well that's basically what
it meant to repeal alcohol prohibition
when they repealed alcohol prohibition
it was left up to the states what to do
with alcohol and so you have most of the
Republican presidential candidates
saying the federal government should not
interfere if States want to legalize
that's really an amazing development but
I think people on the Left have always
have always supported I've always been
critics of the war on drugs have always
supported
form of decriminalization if not
legalization and by large they still do
but what you're starting to see is that
once marijuana actually becomes legal
when you have an industry run by
capitalists that are producing and
selling the stuff progressives start to
get uneasy so they want controls to keep
the operation small maybe even to make
it non profit I mean some people say
people shouldn't go to jail over this
but we don't want big corporations you
know selling marijuana encouraging
people to to consume it as much as
possible and that sort of thing that
scares them they don't like the idea of
big business producing and selling
marijuana so you start going to start to
see some cleavages there between
libertarians and progressives on what
what should regulation look like after
legalization I'd like to talk about one
of my all-time favorite Jacob solemn
moments your appearance on The O'Reilly
Factor so most famously he had you
wanted to talk about saying yes your
book and he when he had you on he got
into a kind of a heated discussion with
you and he called you a dangerous
pinhead why would you an intelligent guy
want to put forth a theory that
intoxicating oneself is beneficial why
would you want to do that with the
enormous social problems that we have in
this country the biggest component of
what you're talking about involves legal
drugs my point it doesn't matter whether
it's legal or illegal in heads like you
are encouraging intoxication it what is
one of the worst things in our society
have we crossed that point now where
people believe that or is there still a
large percent of the population that
that thinks the way that O'Reilly does
there are still a lot of people who just
see marijuana is a symbol of evil and
they just can't get over it and a lot of
them are conservatives who who think
that with marijuana comes ideological
and cultural baggage that they did that
alienates them and they can't get beyond
that you know they can't see it is
simply a plant then at certain
properties that can be used for certain
things that has certain risks and
benefits they will never able to see it
rationally because of this of this
emotional connotation that it has for
them Jacobson thank you so much for
talking with us hyper
Janet sir like it I'm Todd crane in for
reason TV